what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion I'm
one of the best players in the world
according to my HIV people say I would
be good in the Premier League but first
I need to be good in Syria thanks Kappa
but we actually need a Champions League
goalkeeper so let's cut the crap
Jesus back
it's go beat all right I can't sleep I
haven't slept since that day we were in
total control then he took it away my
question is we decided on the sizes of
the paintings
[Music]
no and one you are not an end look you
only need cojones in your heart come on
let's talk somewhere else that doesn't
smell like a port-o-potty look you're
great and one your hair deserves to be
up there with the legends but do you why
not I'm just as good as fun all done
messy at what I won the World Cup
Oh pop I won the world shut up and
follow
the book no one reads okay so apparently
there's some kind of secret Fight Club
going on in the basement yeah so we
never told anyone about the secret Fight
Club because he's always got thousands
of cameras following him oh wait [ __ ]
the first rule of Fight letting go is
you do not talk about Fight Latika
unless a streaming service offers you a
lot of money I don't got it like how
much money the second rule of Fight let
go is if you do talk about my let it go
because a streaming service offered to a
lot of money don't take tax advice from
your family
smells so seriously like how much money
the third rule of Fight Club to get a
red card for violent conduct is easy to
get your opponent sent off for doing
nothing that is the work of a true ask
this is the real Nutley Atlanta toss
time I know I'm not the not led to come
player but they told me they had a safe
space for violence oh yes please
[Music]
I came back all right I'm ready
you got a play to the whistle after hey
what's going on
tough guys grabbing your cojones this is
you this is what you look like
and this is what you look like I knocked
you out of the Champions League and I
can knock you over here I did okay I
didn't touch him stop should I stop
shaking your head disapprovingly people
love me you all love me right cool man
show a really really good-looking
Wow you are shameless
hi Emma legend legends news trophies
okay bye
[Music]
[Music]
good fight what did you say about me
Madre
cabin I Kevin so you just basically
telling people to subscribe to the BR
football channel on YouTube the borona I
guess that works too